and it's so awesome to be back but I'm
deeply jealous because we didn't have
this engineering club when I was here
every single year I come back and get
more and more jealous about how often
you guys have had it but Stanford was
the best place to have an undergraduate
degree as you'll see in my presentation
so to answer what the Bay of AB tree is
it's this tree that is native to
Madagascar and my co-founder Erik
Darnell directed all for Madagascar
films so we thought it made sense also
it has an amazing story because I'm
going to talk about storytelling today
about how the gods were angry at this
tree so they threw the tree down and it
fell upside down and its roots where the
branch is instead and its head was
became the roots and that's why such a
funny looking tree but the mission of
our company is to inspire you to dream
by bringing out your sense of wonder and
we felt this tree really showed that so
I'm going to talk today about defining
your own path I'm going to tell you
about my path to becoming an
entrepreneur I never expected to become
an entrepreneur
I'm deeply introverted deeply insecure
quartz origin so I didn't think I would
have what it took to become an
entrepreneur but through my path from
Stanford to eBay through Zynga from
Hollywood Pixar etc I found my voice and
that was always by not allowing other
people to tell me who I was and who I
could be it's like am i a woman or my
man and my introvert or extrovert am I a
fuzzy or a techie am I a suit or a
creative and it's rejecting all that and
defining your own path and saying that
you can be whatever you want and don't
follow the buckets that people want to
put you in so my path I started off at
Stanford I knew I want to do
entertainment so I looked up all the
Studios job openings before coming to
Stanford and saw what did they want me
to major in it says
Communications and econ usually I took
those classes but I love computer
science and most because it was the most
difficult
they found that really intellectually
stimulating so I started doing that and
then doing symbolic systems because then
I started getting excited about logic
and then I took a class at Stanford
University Digital Arts Center and
realized I could combine art with the
psychology with engineering and the
amazing thing about Stanford
is unlike the other schools out there
which are mostly on the semester system
the quarter system allows you to take as
many classes as you want so I took all
sorts of classes like coastal
environmental zone where I was able to
travel different beaches on the
California coast and study them she's
the best class ever highly recommend
that you guys take that class but I fell
in love with animation in particular and
I sought to design my own major and
Stanford is one of these schools that
allows you to do it I think Brown is the
only other school I believe that lets
you do it Stanford doesn't believe that
you know what you want to do until
you've tried out a bunch of classes
which is totally true
so I designed my major here and then I
went to eBay so why did I go to eBay
when I wanted to do animation it's
called Tiger parents so I really wanted
to do animation so badly but my parents
I'm Asian
my Chinese parents told me that I would
be poor and destitute if I followed my
dreams and that I need to do something
practical so instead of following my
dreams to lucasville I took a job at
eBay which was also super awesome so no
diss on eBay because it also used our
psychology and computer science but that
was great but the entire time I was
there I would take classes at De Anza
College Community College because all
the Lucasfilm animators would teach
there so at night time I take the
classes thinking about the day that my
stock options would be worth enough so I
could finally escape and do my true
passion but by taking these classes at
night I really learned about the skill
of animation and continued to define my
own path there instead of just doing one
thing I also found that by drawing every
single day and doing art and made me
better at my job at eBay on the business
side which I thought was really strange
because I thought it was also always
about focusing and just doing one thing
but by being cross-disciplinary that's
when you start finding connections
between the different disciplines the
best advice I ever got was from a
professor here her name was Laurie Loeb
she was a visiting professor and she
taught animation she's at Dartmouth now
leading up animation and back when I was
at Stanford when I was all angsty about
180 to animate
my parents not letting me she said don't
worry about knowing what you want to do
the most important thing is to do
whatever job it is that you have and do
it really well because you'll learn
something that will help you in your
path later and the people around you who
see you work so hard with your work
ethic will come out of the Woodworks
later on and help you and I'll show you
through the path how that actually did
happen so finally after doing eBay five
years it's time I've saved up enough
money it's time to pursue my passion and
I was gonna apply to Art Center to get
an MFA but guess what the deadlines had
passed and I was really sad and my mom
said why don't you apply to round three
of business school and I thought cuz I
hate business but like a dutiful
Confucian daughter I applied to Harvard
and I got in but I was gonna say no
because I knew I just really wanted to
this animation thing it's very stubborn
but my boss at eBay said don't be an
idiot Maureen you think Hollywood's so
cool it's sexy but you don't know don't
say no what Harvard first go try it out
and then make your decision so I emailed
everyone in the Stanford alumni beta
database that had anything to do with
entertainment animation like five years
or so and they all responded me to me
because the Stanford alumni database and
network is very strong and they gave me
all sorts of internships in Hollywood so
I quit my job at eBay drove down to
Hollywood I took on every single
internship I could possibly get my hands
on to learn so I was just doing script
development with Michael elenberg who is
now the HBO drama dude and also talent
manager assistant to Joseph
gordon-levitt and that graph and
Palladino and I learned from that
experience that everything is a business
at the end of the day and that my mom is
always right but I should go to business
school something went ahead and went to
business school where I ran for
president entertainment media Club but
there I was super angsty too because
they are mostly from the East Coast and
they would say oh you're that creative
person and I was put in math camp
because I didn't come from a finance and
consulting background at the time and
found my own path there so internship
between business school years the most
important thing you can do in Business
School so I apply to Pixar a lyric
money who is a graduate of Stanford GSB
was the CFO of Pixar and he's like oh
you should totally come to accounting
finance
I hate accounting so I know I don't
wanna do that I want to get paid minimum
wage to bring coffee for the crew of the
Pixar staff but they were angsty about
that too because they said you're from
business school you belong here with the
numbers you're a suit you're not a
creative so I had to fight real hard to
form a path to make sure that I got the
internship that I wanted and the amazing
thing there is because I told my boss on
Toy Story 3 sets Department what it is I
want to learn which was how to become a
producer she designed an internship for
me we're usually interns get to only
stay with one department I was with
assets Department they make all the
environments you can only stay with one
department the whole time she formed an
internship where I could shadow every
single department editorial art
characters etc and that's because I told
her what it is that I wanted the point
is to always ask her what you want
because people general want to make you
happy and want to help you and if you
don't ask for it it's not gonna happen
so especially for ladies out there you
definitely have to do this because dudes
just naturally do it not to generalize
so I worked on Toy Story 3 in production
and then after that instead of going
back to Pixar because I realized from my
newly awesome Harvard Business School
education that starting an animation
company was really hard because if I had
one flop of a film if I didn't have a
theme-park division to buffer against
the loss my entire company would
probably go down also and fit unless I
had huge amounts of capital or unfair
distribution advantage it probably
didn't make sense to go compete against
the Disney Pixar DreamWorks but I was
also attracted to startups and Pixar was
a very mature industry at the time and I
want to be part of something new
creating a new industry so I joined
singer right when they started and was
there for six years and I started off on
farmville and became vice president of
games after six years looking over the
farm bill franchise and that was crazy I
did not sleep and I slept four hours a
night clicking refresh on my computer at
like 2:00 a.m. in the morning to see if
the numbers are gonna go down because I
didn't want Mark Pincus to yell at me
this hurt went down because he has a
dashboard every morning where he sees
every game and day every day change and
week over a week and if it was red and
down and you were in trouble so I was
constantly clicking refresh is traumatic
but I learned so much about what it
meant to be an entrepreneur and what it
took to start a company because in
business school they teach you to be a
certain type of leader which is very
different from what it takes to be a
startup leader it requires different
management styles for different types of
company and if you've heard of wartime
CEO versus peacetime CEO it's very
relevant you should definitely read that
it's I can't remember it's by Ben
Horowitz orange recent Horowitz so you
should definitely read that because it
will turn your thinking upside down on
what it means to be a leader so but even
when I was a zinger just loved animation
so in nights and weekends despite
sleeping four hours a day I worked on a
short animated film called the dam
keeper with my two friends from Pixar
and we made a short film that ended up
getting nominated for the Oscars so that
was awesome I just couldn't stop doing
animation but I couldn't figure out how
to make it work from a business
perspective so I had this art side of my
brain right what I really loved my
passion my idealism and then I had this
super business school practical Asian
parents side of my brain and what I was
trying to do this entire time is figure
out can I merge the two together can I
be both or do I have to end up choosing
to be one or another but every single
step I took I try to create my own path
in the role that I wanted instead of
letting them put me where they wanted to
which is why I started my own company
because then you can make it whatever
you want so these are my three
co-founders and Eric like I said he
directed all for Madagascar films and
ants and Larry Cutler Stanford grad both
undergrad and master's in computer
science and his thesis I believe was
even on VR back in long time ago where's
not even commercially viable but now
very relevant and he went to Pixar right
when he graduated a technical director
and then became DreamWorks head of all
character technology and he's a judge
for the Oscar technical achievement
words so the reason I put this light up
isn't to brag even though they're sweet
they're
and what this up is to explain how I got
in touch with these people and how the
path helped Erik Darnell I met through
Glenn dentists Glenn dentist is a
co-founder of pdi/dreamworks animation
and this former CTO of DreamWorks
interactive and the CEO became EA LA and
he was the CEO of DreamWorks interactive
he was a consultant advisor at Ginga and
as soon as I realized what he did in the
past you will be my mentor he said no I
retired on time and my wife wants me at
home I don't tie for you and I said I'm
gonna become best friends with your wife
and he says we'll see you about that so
it all worked out and friends okay and
he's now my advisor and so when Isis I
start this company I asked him hey can
you introduce me to Eric because he
hired Eric into DreamWorks for his first
job Eric was an animation intern and
became a big badass director so he
introduced me to him now Larry remember
when I said I emailed everyone in the
Stanford alumni database to get a job he
was one of the people I emailed and he
was one of the people who responded he
said do not go to basically everyone
said do not go to business school and I
totally ignored everything they said
which he says was a good decision now we
can always justify your past uh-huh so
Larry I kept in touch with and I ran
into him during a Chinese new year's
parade in San Francisco where he was
taking pictures of his daughter fan
dancing I was like hey he's like what
are you doing I said I'm starting a
company he's like oh maybe I should join
you and that's how it all happens
oh it's been one month I found my two
co-founders and then Glen antis
introduced me Alvy Ray Smith the
co-founder of Pixar I emailed him to be
my advisor he's like listen marina hate
games I don't believe in VR sorry's not
gonna happen I said let me just meet you
so I met him at the crate Vai and I put
the headset on him which is a mobile
headset he's like I'm gonna be your
advisor so it's about persistence and
constantly asking and then he introduced
me to Glen Keane who is my favorite out
of all these I know you're not supposed
to have favorites but he's my favorite
all of these because he was the
directing animator of Little Mermaid
Beauty and the Beast
Pocahontas all those things there Tarzan
tangled a lot in he's the most famous
anime
alive so he joined our advisory board as
well Eric knew me race thoria the
president she's now the president
paramount she was the president of
DreamWorks Animation and then through
all this stuff I applied to Tribeca Film
Festival to show our piece and then
became friends with Jane Rosenthal who
heads up Tribeca Film Festival and as
Robert De Niro's producing partner but
the point of all this is it's all
through networking and it's all through
being persistent and asking each person
to help you introduce you to another
person and even if they say no you
persist until they say yes because
people in general do want to help you
okay so then I went about getting
investors and this all happened as well
in a month I had unrealistic
expectations I thought I would get
funding in two weeks and it was I took
me four weeks to get funding which is
really good but I thought I was a
massive failure at three weeks oh no and
I was under the covers crying like oh no
I'm never gonna get money for this
company but what was interesting is it
was again through my network that I got
all this investment the first one who
lend my series a 6 million was Gavin teo
i knew him because he was a PM a zynga
and while no one believed a VR at the
time especially not content he told his
bosses okay it doesn't matter if you
even believe and what Morgan's doing
she's crazy because I know she was at
Zynga and she'll find a way to make you
money so just give her money it was
really helpful that I were dead singer
with Gavin and then through the
Taiwanese Network so Steve Chang was a
founder of Tiburon who makes all of
sports and Madden franchise EA bought
them he introduced me to Phil Chen who
is a chief content officer of HTC and
the person who created the HTC vive he
introduced me to him because Phil Chen
want to figure out how to bridge more
Taiwanese Silicon Valley connections we
spoke and then he liked what I was doing
introduced me to the CEO of HTC as she
immediately said I want to give you
money so that was su that Taiwanese
connection Samsung was just at a dinner
I met a Jason who's the best VC ever and
you should all go seek funding from him
i sat next to him at a dinner he just
really impressed me and he's like all
right every money I meant
I know it's making it sound really easy
really awful fundraising was the worst
experience of my life other than you
know getting broken up with but it was
still you know a difficult experience
but with the right connections in
prisons you can do it too and then Phil
Chen eventually went to horizons venture
who is the biggest fund in China along
with Alibaba and 10 cent and so he
introduced me to the head of the fun
there as well and then Mark Pincus was
my old boss and I was like mark you owe
me farmville can pay money and so he
also introduced me to Peter Thiel and
through other connections to yoku and
for entertainment we have Comcast's
ventures like I said 20th Century Fox
turn in Peter turn in advance it is the
run by Shari redstone the chairwoman by
staring them in a paramount Viacom and
evolution media capital which is CAA and
TPG so an SMG is the biggest media
conglomerate in all of China because you
know China's where all entertainments
going so you want to make sure I have
access to that market one thing you'll
find interesting here is they teach in
Business School not to go for strategics
you should go for financial institutions
I found that strategics have been
incredibly helpful to me because I knew
that VR was going to take forever
all these people going to pitch me
either like oh it's here VR is here I
did the opposite thing I said be ours
not here here I was gonna take forever
and because of that I need an investor
who's gonna stay with me for the long
term are you the one because you should
be honored that I'm even talking to you
and you should be honored to give me
money so that's the attitude by the way
you have to take when you funding but
the strategics for health would because
they were invested in VR themselves so
they cared about the art they needed to
succeed so they need my content so they
can ride out the waves the bumpy the
hype cycle you know the the Gartner hype
cycle traffic dissolution and all that
wave and so they've provided a lot of
help and they know where things are
going because they have all the data
right for their headsets they give me
all that information they tell me what
their strategy is they give me free
technology all that so it's been
actually quite helpful for me to have
strategic investors okay how many of you
are athletes
hey how many of you are musicians or
singer-songwriters how about astronauts
nice one
okay so usually because you guys are
young and idealistic and wonderful you
guys actually raise your hands but
usually if I were to ask this question
to a room of adults
nobody would raise their hand and when
you're five years old you all thought
you could be all those things so the
question is if you don't believe that
you can be all these things now what
happened from when you were five to
becoming an adult that made you think
that some of these things were no longer
possible right maybe someone told you
your sculpture and art class wasn't
quite right or you had a tiger parent
who told you you should be more
practical but deep down inside we
believe that everyone has the dreamer is
still inside and we know this to be true
because it's why you guys all go to the
movies it's why you go watch games play
games it's because you want to meet
characters and be in situations and
scenarios that you wouldn't necessarily
encounter in real life and that is what
we care about and this is why I love
animation I love animation so much that
I couldn't stop trying to get back to
animation through that entire path right
and animation to me is all about taking
in two completely different worlds ones
that you could have never imagined and
making them feel so real that you think
you could reach out and touch it and
those last two sentences I just said
down there takes you to a different
world and makes it real that's the
definition of VR and AR which is why I
think that VR and animation and AR are
made for each other and the mission of
our company ultimately is to bring you
back to that five-year-old self in your
city that you have inside you to bring
out your sense of wonder and inspire you
to dream again because then you would
all go for your dreams you would realize
how much potential you have actually go
for it rather than being scared that you
can't achieve your dream and what a
awesome place the world would be if
everyone actually pursued their dreams
so I want to show you really quickly
what the company does and I'll dive into
storytelling well I think it's important
for Humanity and have illusion and
storytelling as well
bamm-bamm studios were focused on doing
immersive storytelling in virtual
reality
with characters that audiences can fall
in love with when I watching animation I
feel that I'm taken back to that
five-year-old sense of self where I
thought anything was possible and our
mission is to inspire the world to dream
by bringing out your sense of wonder oh
I had been working for over 20 years
directing feature animated films and put
on a VR headset for the first time it
blew me away it's like this undiscovered
frontier
we see virtual reality is a new medium
for telling stories and creating great
cinematic experiences that are character
driven it allows people to be taken to
places in two worlds that otherwise
wouldn't exist when audiences saw
invasion they reacted to the world and
the characters in ways we never imagined
and that interactivity in that
connection that eye contact was really
significant and we realized we were
really on to something so then when hand
controllers came out we started our next
piece asteroids determined to make the
viewer character inside this story that
had hands that can actually interact
with the world around them Crowe the
legend was a piece that we always wanted
to do from the very beginning it started
off as a Native American folk tale that
was spread through word and we are
turning it into a VR animation to take
the story to the next level that sounds
like another way we look at what we're
doing at Bev EV Studios is to take
advantage of what we already know about
the empathy of filmmaking and cinema and
the interactivity of games and the
motivation to act that we have in real
life when things really matter and we
really care and so when we have all
those pieces of the puzzle working
together then we have an experience
that's unlike an experience you could
have in any other medium
[Music]
how many of you have tried VR wow that's
amazing okay how about a are ya arts
gonna have the same problems that VR has
just secret okay so why did I start this
company so the first time I put on a VR
headset I hated it I um was watching
that Paul McCartney music video and it's
like oh you can be right there but all I
could notice was the poor resolution and
the pixels cuz the headsets weren't
advanced enough but when I put on the
headset when I was at Zynga we hacked
our game into it for fun
it wasn't even it wasn't even moving
there was no animated image it was just
a cartoon right in the background and I
realized that this is a future of
animation because animation for - when
you watch animation its suspension of
disbelief right you don't expect it to
look real and you get completely sucked
in so you're not noticing the pixels
versus when you're doing real life or
you know special effects you have we we
care so much about whether or not it
looks real or not which is why sometimes
like if you guys watch the old Final
Fantasy movies you know it feels kind of
weird you can tell that they're not
really human so I was really excited my
like oh my gosh I need to go do this
Amelia and you join a company but I
couldn't find a company that did what I
wanted to do so that's why I had to
start the company so who is it because I
always thought I want to be an
entrepreneur because it's really hard
totally worthwhile they're really hard
and so I kind of stumbled my way into it
and I love storytelling so there's this
theory how many of you have read the
book sapiens yes so there's this theory
evolutionary theologist not theologists
researchers believe that the reason why
somos epeans might have been survival
fittest and won out is because of rumors
which is our ability to tell stories you
can say there's a lion over there don't
go over there or someone's like hey
Hector killed the lion with this chisel
in this way and are all the kids around
the camp are like oh my gosh I want to
be just like Hector it's about putting
yourself in another
viewpoint and putting yourself another
scenario and you kind of wonder what
would I do if I were in that situation
but in VR you don't have to wonder you
actually are in that situation you
actually have to act and it reveals who
you are but storytelling is extremely
powerful because it gets you to care so
much about a character that you want to
watch to the end of it right because you
want to know what happens to that
character you want them to fail you want
them to succeed and we believe that VR
na are let's you care about that
character even more so than all its
previous videos so to give you example
you see this scene right here in
invasion which is a first experiment
that we ever did little bunny comes up
and sniffs you now this isn't you know
crazy because if you think about if you
watch Deadpool write Deadpool comes up
and talks to you it's called breaking
the fourth wall
you don't usually in cinema break the
fourth wall the player doctors don't
acknowledge you because you're in your
theater sea and you kind of know that
Deadpool is not actually talking to you
but this weird thing happens in VR
people would actually get on the ground
and start bouncing around mimicking her
motions absolutely sure that she was
reacting to them when actually it was
canned animation of the time they would
try to reach out and pet her they would
crew at her they would talk to her they
would wave at her and there's this scene
where the aliens had their lasers
pointed at you and she's hiding behind
you and people say oh my gosh I'm a
bunny shield I need to save her and sit
and I can feel the snow and her breath
on my shoulder and it was really the air
conditioning in our office but they just
believed it to be real because when
you're in VR your animal brain makes you
believe that this thing is real and how
powerful is that if you start believing
that she's real how much more do you
bond with her how much more do you want
to see what happens
how much more responsibility do you feel
you have for her and want to actually
help her right and this ended up at the
beginning no one gave us a time of day
we started our company because they're
like no I also watch animation and
comedy they only want hardcore zombie
shooting games this ended up becoming
the number one downloaded experience
across all headsets beating out all the
games being on all the licensed IP and
all that and we think it's because of
this specific moment because after it
it's people like I want that bunny and
we made a plushie bunny so they can hug
it but tell your friends about it and
then if you're a person and you buy at
Christmas and you want to share it with
your kids or your nieces and nephews or
your grandma what are you going to show
them right you're not going to necessary
have them shoot zombies right you loves
to remember cute bunny that's gonna come
talk to you so we want to take our
learnings from that moment when she's
making eye contact with you and put that
into asteroids and then hand controllers
came out so he said can we make you not
only care about these characters because
you believe they're real but can you do
something about that caring now turning
empathy into action is called compassion
can we get you to act on behalf of these
characters so in asterisks you are this
menial task or but you're the lowest of
the low you're in space with mac and
cheese are to aliens and you're with
peas is your robot sidekick and you are
helping them on your mission but you
suck and they don't respect you but by
the end if you help them enough you
redeem yourself you have your own little
character arc you save somebody's life
and you become a respected member of
their team and they bow at you and thank
you at the end and you become a
respected member so that was really
interesting because we wanted to test
with that but we also learned that
interactivity a lot of people have tried
to merge games and film together it's
really hard because when you put
interactivity in there people just want
to push all the buttons and interact and
they completely ignore the story right
but by putting interactivity in there
then they become even more immersed so
it's trying to figure out that fine line
between the two things so we iterated on
kro so oh by the way we won an Emmy for
both invasions and asteroids so we're
really excited about that and we got
ethan hawke for invasion and for
asteroids we had ingrid nilsen the
famous youtuber as well as Elizabeth
Banks because I'm all about casting
women and for crow The Legend this one's
gonna launch really soon it's starring
John Legend who is the star and also
executive producer Oprah Kai Sheridan
from ready player one Constance Wu from
crazy rich Asians and fresh off the boat
my favorite show of all time
Liza Koshi the top number two youtuber
and also diego luna from rogue one so we
have a sweet sweet calf and we are poor
start ok not that poor because we raised
but still poor so like you know stars so
it's like how did we have I have to
pinch myself how did we get all these
people to be excited about being in our
project and for them it was about the
themes of this piece so crow is about
based off of Native American tale about
how the crow used to have gorgeous
rainbow feathers colorful feathers and
how he became the crow that you know
today a black with the cawing voice and
basically what happens is it becomes a
winter on earth before us all it's like
Eden beautiful it becomes cold and crow
is the one who has to sacrifice himself
by flying into the Sun to bring fire and
warmth back to the earth but in the
process and flying to the Sun his
feathers turn all black they get burned
and his voice becomes like the crow his
voice today and there's deep Native
American themes about sacrifice and
community and what we learned through
this process and of adapting it is
Native Americans were put into
reeducation camps and told that they
weren't allowed to tell these stories
because they were pagan and so we're
really excited about being able to tell
these types of stories and partnered
with Native Americans and philanthropy
in order to tell the story so we have
Sara Eagle heart which is the coolest
name ever
and also Randy Edmunds who's a tribal
elder who voiced characters in here but
also helped us to make sure that we were
true to the original vision but in this
one we made you the spirit of the
seasons so you are the who makes
it winter so you wave your hands around
sorry if I'm allowed to curse but they
say there's a study that says that the
more you curse the more successful and
entrepreneur you are so
so instead of having you push buttons
because we don't want people when you're
in the headset we don't want you think
which button do I need to press to make
what happened because that's takes you
out of the experience we decided we
wanted it to be seamless so you don't
have to push any buttons you just wave
your arms around and that is what
incites the action and so when you wave
your hands this way you make the flowers
bloom and when you wave your hands you
make a snowfall and so you turn into
winter and you make it so that the
animals are frigid and maybe going to
die and if for a synchro to go but we
wanted to see if this time instead of
being a fly on the wall or a passive
viewer or someone just with arms what is
it like if you have power over these
creatures but they don't know you exist
you have responsibility what do you
choose to do as a human being I want you
to try to screw with them or will you
actually try to help them and we're
really excited about this piece as you
notice the cast that we cast I want to
make sure that it was an inclusive cast
because especially in Hollywood there
are very few minorities or women behind
in front of the camera so that's
something that I felt was important
which I also think is very important in
VR because it's combining two super
male-dominated industries right you have
tech and you have gaming the two
industries I come from and when we're
creating a completely new industry it's
the we have a chance to actually make
sure that women are there from the
really beginning which by the way means
that there needs to be women where the
money's at because there was a study I
believe from Stanford that showed that a
woman who's doing a presentation for
pitching to a VC with the same exact
pitch deck as a male is I believe 40%
less likely to get funding the exact
same pitch and I think the Stanford
study was showing slides with a female
voiceover versus a male voiceover same
exact dick woman was less likely to get
funding so you gotta fix that and you
guys can do it so for a lot of ladies
would be great if you guys didn't only
be the ones to start companies but also
are the money because that's where a lot
of powers ads like who you decide to
fund ultimately okay so if there was a
little girl crying on a park bench let's
say Central Park and she
too young to be by herself if you see
her crying in a film you're gonna feel
really bad for her but you're probably
not gonna get out of your seats right
and go like touch the screen and try to
help her because it's in the theater in
a game you'd go talk to her but maybe
the reason you talk to her is because
you're trying to win you're trying to
get a key get information to solve a
quest get to the next level it may be
very egocentric it's the story of you in
real life you would go talk to her
because you genuinely care about her and
you're worried about her and you want to
save her right so we believe that VR AR
allows you to have the empathy of film
where you care so much about that
character you have the agency of games
where you can do something about your
caring but you do it because you
genuinely care not because you're trying
to win and we think this is the magic of
what VR AR gives us and it's a
completely new medium and something that
we are super excited about so I'm just
gonna conclude that's why I love VR is
why I love animation but the real theme
of entire pieces do not allow anyone to
ever bucket you into any category that
you can absolutely define your own path
like every single step of the way people
are trying to tell me even that Pixar
every step of the way people want you to
be one thing or another you just refuse
to do that and you say what it is that
you want and the people around you who
respect you will help you get what it is
that you want but you have to say that
you want it because you all have much
more potential than you realize and as
you grow older you're still young
idealistic which is great and keep it
real but there's this tendency for
society to try to get you to conform to
societal values of money fame fortune
Beauty just resist that and remember who
you are today because this is the
version of yourself and the idealism
that you want to keep especially if you
want to start something new thank you
you